en esta ocasión tenemos diferentes
incógnitas aquí tenemos una línea en
blanco un signo de interrogación una
carita feliz una a un ave y una estrella
lo que en este vídeo vamos a buscar es
encontrar qué significa cada una de
estas incógnitas así es que los invito a
que ustedes pausa en el vídeo y puedan
empezar a hacerlo poco a poco ustedes
solos o nos esperamos a tenerlo todos
juntos y lo hacemos en un momento
quiero pensar que realmente estuvieron
pendientes de hacer estos solitos de
cualquier manera vamos a hacer cada uno
de ellos empezaremos con este 3 por
blanco es igual a 12 y realmente lo que
aquí ocupamos saber es si yo multiplico
este 3 por un número me va a dar 12 así
es que vamos a nuestras tablas del 3 y
nos podemos preguntar 3 por 1 es igual a
3 3 por 2 es igual a 6 3 por 3 es igual
a 9 3 por 4 es igual a 12 justo aquí
tenemos el 12 y con eso podemos decir
entonces que nosotros multiplicamos 3
por 1 2 3 4 veces 3 por 4 es igual a 12
y esto es absolutamente correcto así es
que pondremos nuestra respuesta aquí
3 x 4 es igual a 12 vamos más adelante
ahora con este signo de interrogación
entre 4 es igual a 6 una manera en la
que también podemos pensar esto es el
signo de interrogación va a ser igual a
6 x 4 si yo multiplico 6 por 4 tendré
este signo de interrogación porque
originalmente este signo de
interrogación es un número tan grande
que si lo divido entre 4 me dará igual a
6 recuerda que tenemos también la
posibilidad de decir 4 por 6 o 6 por 4
así es que si empezamos con la tabla del
6 multiplicaremos 6 por 16 6 por 2 12
muy bien 6 por 3 18 6 por 4 24 y con eso
tendremos entonces la respuesta 6 por 4
es igual a 24 podemos decir que el signo
de interrogación es igual a 24
pongamos el resultado aquí signo de
interrogación será igual a 24
esta es nuestra respuesta para este
ejercicio vamos más adelante con el 54
es igual a 9 por carita feliz de entrada
aquí tenemos el símbolo de
multiplicación por lo que será muy
sencillo hemos de buscar qué número
multiplicado por nueve nos dará 54 y
para ello haremos nuestra tabla del 9
vamos a ver 9 por 19 9 por 2 18 9 por 3
27 simplemente estoy sumando de 9 9 y lo
ven 9 por 4 36 9 por 5 45 9 por 6 54
aquí tenemos entonces no
por 6 es igual a 54 vamos bien eso
implica que nuestra carita feliz será
igual a 6 así es que pongamos aquí
carita feliz
es igual a 6 y por lo tanto 9 por 6 es
igual a 54 y tenemos completamente
cierto y correcto nuestro resultado 54
es igual a 9 por 6 vamos bien avancemos
ahora hacia esta ecuación que tenemos
aquí 9 es igual a entre 8 y recuerda lo
que hicimos aquí
despejamos la a de tal manera que si yo
tengo un número grande que lo divida
entre 8 me dará 9 entonces sabré que es
el número
es igual a 9 por 8
estamos claro si yo tengo nueve por ocho
tendré un número enorme que es lo mismo
que decir que si ese número enorme lo
divido entre ocho tendré como resultado
nueve de hecho ya empezamos la tabla del
9 recuerden la tenemos aquí abajo vamos
a seguir la 9 por 6 54 9 por 7 es igual
a 63 9 por 8 es igual a 72
aquí tenemos 9 x 8 es igual a 72
así es que podemos sustituir esta por el
72 72 es igual a 9 por 8 que es justo lo
que tenemos aquí abajo de las tablas
podemos entonces decir que a es igual a
72 porque simplemente sustituir el valor
de a y tengo la ecuación correcta uno
más tenemos b es igual a 20 entre 5
recuerda que también aquí podemos hacer
lo siguiente 20
será igual
aquel número multiplicado por cinco
si yo multiplico un número por 5 me dará
20 o lo que es lo mismo si tengo ese 20
y lo divido entre 5 me dará ese número
vamos a hacer la tabla del 5 así es que
5 por 15 5 por 2
5 por 3 15 5 por 4 20 aquí tenemos la
respuesta 20
5 x 4 es igual a 20
y entonces podemos decir que b es igual
a 4
que de hecho si nosotros multiplicamos 5
por 4 nos dará 20 como lo hicimos aquí o
podemos decir que 4 es igual a 20 entre
5 de ustedes tienen 20 pelotas y la
dividen en 5 grupos grandes
cada grupo de pelotas tendrá 4 lo pueden
hacer en casa como experimento y verán
que el resultado es adecuado
la última tenemos estrellita x 2 es
igual a 14 qué número está representando
esta estrellita de tal manera que cuando
lo multiplique por dos me dará 14 vamos
a hacer entonces la tabla del 2 les
parece bien 2 por 1 2 2 por 2 4 2 por 3
2 por 48 simplemente voy sumando de dos
en dos en cada avance 2 por 5 10
2 x 6 12 2 por 7 14
y tiene todo el sentido si yo tengo 7
por 2 será 14 y eso es correcto si yo
tengo aquí 1234567 puedo decir que
estrellita
es igual a 7 y al sustituirlo en la
ecuación tengo 7 por 2 es igual a 14 lo
que es absolutamente correcto